british embassy residents
it's beautiful you're not just scanning
out the place to rob it
cozy about just running in there
do not approach this one
good morning guys here in budapest
hungary in my opinion
one of the most beautiful cities in the
world
but if you're here to see all the
beautiful sights
the tourist attractions don't watch this
video this video is about
contrast the contrast between
the wealthy and the poor so we're going
to go to
a beautiful neighborhood to start this
and then go to the
other side of the tracks which is
actually near the tracks
near the train tracks to show
the other story i always love doing
this type of work where you dive into
the contrast
of a place and just show the different
narratives and the different stories
that co-exist
this isn't every big city so today
it's budapest i think you'll like it
and of course we got to meet some people
run into some of the locals
that's always my always my mission okay
let's do this
[Music]
is the name this neighborhood which
means
i believe rose hill and this is on the
buddha side of the city
so it was two cities before buddha and
passed on both sides of the river
now it's budapest locals say budapest
so here we have a nice home i'm not
gonna
be the architect here and tell you
exactly what style that is
what i can say is it's beautiful
where are the the nicest homes this
direction
all over i guess all over okay
this is interesting
beautiful vegetation in here old growth
trees
got a few modern buildings sprinkled in
here
but overall this looks like old
hungarian money
could be wrong on that maybe the film
stars
live here budapest is a fascinating
place it's
it's seen a little bit of everything i
mean the mongols
killed roughly half the population
before that it was the romans after the
mongols you have the uh
the ottomans in this neighborhood
was where a lot of i read it's where the
a lot of the ottomans the turks
lived when they controlled budapest i
think that was
part of the 15th and 16th centuries
yeah then it was capital co-capital the
austrian
hungarian empire the soviets
put their toes in here for a while a
satellite state of the soviet union
and now hungary is on its own
that is just a little breeze by of the
history here
i like the fact that these fences are so
tiny if someone wanted to get in
they could you have a window on the
lower level
without bars some with bars but some
without
and i feel like when a society fails
is when you have to have huge electric
fences
around places like this guard dogs
guards you know completely off limits
people have to really just barricade
themselves in
and it's not that feel here
feels like i am the only one on these
streets and i promise
this video will get more exciting when
we go to the other side of the tracks
here's some more beauty though just some
basic cars
an old chevy a citroen
i'm not a fan of chevy but i do not
understand
with all the choices in this world for
what to buy as far as the car goes
why anyone would buy a french car
and you'd only know if you drove one and
then compared with pretty much any other
car in the world
[Music]
british flag it's not the consulate
because i just went by there okay it's
the uh
british embassy residence guys looking
high here in budapest
beautiful home we've got a nice backyard
zone here
through the trees swimming pool a lot of
these embassy workers
live quite well yeah so a lot of these
government workers
living abroad huh
it's beautiful it's beautiful
are you surprised that you feel me oh
these gardens are amazing
i'm just doing uh videos of this
beautiful neighborhood
okay are you the british counselor uh
i'm my husband's british champion okay
cool yeah how do you like it here it's
wonderful
yeah do you live here i'm here for a
couple days that's it unfortunately
okay you're not just scanning out the
place to rob it
no i get better things to do i'm not a
criminal
really why it's the most beautiful home
in the neighborhood
it is i know i like homes okay
how long have you lived here we've lived
here for four years
yeah this neighborhood is absolutely
it's beautiful but you're not hungarian
yeah you can go there hiking and biking
in this direction to the park
yeah if you live uh without family then
the inner city is cool as well to have a
rooftop yeah a terrace or something like
this
ciao looks like a chinese residence
so we have all all the big nationalities
doing their thing here
that guy was from germany just moved
here
it will be interesting to see the
contrast
i've asked quite a few locals there's no
like really
terrible neighborhood i don't think
because i was i was told one the other
day that's
you know considered the bad bad hood
what is it district eight and i walked
around i
actually found it to be quite nice i
guess it's all your perspective
let's jump the tracks and see what the
other side looks like
oh wow cool
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
here we are coletti and this i was told
to the left of the train station is uh
one of the rougher neighborhoods but
coletti uh neighborhood
yes okay yeah definitely a different
vibe though
different feel and smell urine from the
street pissing
but it doesn't feel that bad actually
look at that they have nice
flowers along the whole street to see a
lot of
bars on the doors and windows
i don't think oh there's a sketchy
looking guy coming this way
i'm not gonna turn the camera reminds me
a little bit of catania
in sicily in italy actually nicer than
that though
cleaner it's got some beautiful
architecture
just needs a little sprucing up
maybe night time it's a little sketchier
here
i think i got bad info bad intel
not much to see here i did get one other
place though
one other place that's just like a
building
it's not even really a neighborhood it's
a building
and i was directed there some of the
kids there were kids but they're saying
you know if i go there in the day it's
gonna be super dangerous with the camera
so i think we're fine but let's check it
out three miles later
i got a tip this neighborhood haas ooh
and i i'm probably completely
pronouncing that incorrectly
hungarian has many dots and accent marks
but that's how it's spelled that hassou
is the so-called
hardest looking neighborhood in budapest
it doesn't really look like it so far i
think it's in here
i'm not gonna jump the fence but i'll
try going around
the block here
okay so it looks like some people are
living in there
and some places are vacant
definitely not the charm of
where we just were today
i'm not feeling cozy about just
running in there with the camera to be
honest
and the point is not to belittle poverty
or
[Applause]
you know make a mockery of this what i
want to show is there are always
different narratives
occurring in a city and
different stories happening at the same
time so
there will not be a british lady coming
out of one of these places
worried about me robbing her house
tonight
that's not happening i bet there's some
really cool people in here i bet there's
some really nice people
i'm sure there's some drug addicts sure
there's a little bit of everything
do not approach this one
speak english
all right guys i'm not gonna go back i
just had a little
uh not altercation but they weren't
happy to see me let's say
so i'm gonna end it here
that's it guys two sides of the tracks
here in budapest
it is a beautiful city watch all the
other videos and all the beauty
but i just want to give you a flavor on
you know how people live
at the extremes too bad i couldn't get
in there i just
you know sometimes you just got to feel
these things out and if the feeling's
not there
going in with a camera is quite possibly
the dumbest thing you can do
all right just want to share some final
thoughts with you
about that video today and
i gotta say it doesn't always work out
how you want it to uh for example at the
end i would have loved
i would have loved to connect with the
locals in that neighborhood
in that shabbier looking neighborhood
uh you know maybe gone into one of their
apartments
i'm sure there's some very kind people
in there
drank some tea and this showing the
human side
but it didn't work out that way at all i
walked by there and
that that kid
or young 20 something he uh he gave me a
very powerful message without saying
anything he looked at my eyes and was
like
do not shoot video
do not make video here and i got it and
i respected that
and it moved on so
that's just how it works sometimes my
style is about
spontaneity it's about authentic
connections
and sometimes it works out better than
others
so i hope i can i hope i
did bring across the contrast here
though
and every big city has that contrast and
i find this stuff
interesting that's why i'm making it i i
think it is interesting to know that
there are
many narratives happening at the same
time so when someone says budapest is
like this or san francisco is like this
or tehran is like this depends who your
whose glasses you're looking through
right like it depends whose life
you're talking about so that's what i
try to capture
and i just want to say for you know if
any of the people see from the
neighborhood i went to at the end
it's it's not a it's not trying to
criticize
the neighborhood it's actually trying to
do the opposite it was try to like
i'm sure just like anywhere
the the poorest looking neighborhood is
usually looked down upon
and i really wanted to bring out that
human connectivity
it just didn't happen oh well
so until next video guys here
is i'll leave you with this
a look of view the beautiful city
of budapest until next one